live from Los Angeles California the
69th annual Academy Awards
you know the Shrine Auditorium crowd
see we film fans have been doing for 69
years watching the Stars come out
there's double Oscar nominee Billy Bob
Thornton
it's nominated tonight for Best Actress
film AC recording star turned actress
Courtney Love Juliette Binoche up for
supporting actress Tim Robbins and Susan
Sarandon
nominated for the for the player it's
publican jr. Brenda Blethyn and Marianne
jean-baptiste Gregory Hines
close
Nicholas Cage last year's winner there's
Mel Gibson a double winner for last year
second only in interest to the oscars
themselves or what the ladies are
wearing
after director Kenneth Branagh
Quentin Tarantino and Mira Sorvino
Goldie Hawn Kurt Russell and army
Archerd given them the scoop
there's Jim Carrey
why st. best actress Jodie Foster Woody
Harrelson a first-time nominee
Frances McDorman nominated for Fargo
Steve Martin and Diane Keaton there's
Will Smith Chris O'Donnell playing
Batman or Robin in Batman there's Lauren
Bacall first-time nominee all-time star
Kevin Spacey Best Supporting Actor last
year
welcome everyone to the 69th Annual
Academy Awards
the president of the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences director
Arthur Hiller
thank you for dropping by on your way to
the party as the 29th president of the
Academy I welcome you all to our 69th
annual awards there are over 6,000 of us
in the Academy who share at least one
wonderful and fulfilling thing with over
a billion of you out there we love
movies
we don't always love the same movie nor
do we always agree which our art and
which our artless but that's what adds
spice to our awards in the form of
suspense spirited discussion and
emotional clashes still going to the
movies brings us together to share our
humanity and what sometimes feels like
an era of isolation we find ourselves
too often alone with our technology
sitting alone to read our computer
screens or listening to radio and
watching television alone fortunately we
still have our houses of worship ball
games and movies to remind us that we
are related by humanity not machinery so
we in our academy propose an agreement
with you you keep going to the movies
and we'll keep making them